i just want to know
what what really can be done to hold
russia accountable here since you know
russia doesn't really
formally recognize the
the um the icc uh you know these
international
institutions that are meant to you know
dissuade or prevent
these types of crimes um you know what
effect
does it have
on a country like russia
and you know what
what can be done other than um
while this investigation is going on by
the icc what can be done to try and
further protect civilians in ukraine
well thank you kevin for your question
obviously what happened over the weekend
is
completely outrageous
completely unjustifiable and shocking
and i share definitely the strong
feelings canadians
had when they saw pictures and videos of
what happened over the weekend in
ukraine
these are clearly war crimes these are
clearly crimes against humanity and it
is important for canada to play its role
in making sure that there is
accountability
for these acts and these acts cannot go
on punish so that's why we will work
within the international criminal court
to support the prosecutor as
he is investigating the issue
but also they need support they need
funding we will be supporting and
funding
the organization i've also raised the
issue with michelle bachelet
which is the
high commissioner for the
united nations human rights council as
they are also investigating what is
happening and i look forward to having a
conversation with her very soon and
finally i would say we need to make sure
that we continue to put maximum pressure
on the russian regime there needs to be
more sanctions there will be more
sanctions on the part of canada and we
need to work also with partners i'll be
heading to the g7 later this week the g7
needs to do more we need to make sure
that we isolate russia economically
diplomatically and politically
maybe just from the finnish perspective
a couple of uh
additional remarks to to what uh mr
choli said first of all of course this
has been very shocking news in finland
as well the main main news what has
happened in in butcher and what's
happening currently in in places like
like mario paul where the civilians are
in the middle of warfare first of all
it's very important to understand that
war has also rules
and these rules are set by the geneva
conventions and and if you break those
rules you are making making war crimes
and and this is what what it looks like
has happened in butcher and it's at this
moment very important that we collect
all the data we interview those who have
been witnessing these atrocities and we
we have all the data then for the uh
future processes european union has been
very strongly condemning what we have
seen and european union is ready to
prepare of course the next sanction
package for us
thank you ministers we have a lot of
questions uh in line so let's uh try to
be concise while asking
next is a freelance journalist from
canada mr denis copton
please
thank you very much my question is
directed to both ministers today
lithuania expelled russian ambassador
and germany will be expelling 40
diplomats whose
work in germany is not connected with
their diplomatic status
does the government of canada and does
the government of finland intend to
follow lithuanian germany in expelling
some russian diplomats and in general
what are the
our respective governments intentions
regarding the management of our
relationships with russia
from the finnish perspective we of
course follow
very closely always that the diplomats
are are
acting in a real diplomatic work and and
we are ready to to react if this is not
the case and i i don't want to
to to
make any any uh public statement on that
but this is the case now in finland that
we are of course looking
looking the the issue from from that
light that uh diplomats are
uh are doing the job that are they are
here
for well i would add to that and i agree
with
what minister avisto just mentioned i
would say
this is a top priority for government
definitely we're concerned
with any security issues coming from
russian diplomats we take stock of what
lithuania and germany has announced
today and i'll have conversations also
with key cabinet ministers to make sure
that we react promptly